the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
y'all i'm ryan sickler we're over here
doing it at studio night pants this is
the honeydew with y'all as you all know
where i'm highlighting the lowlights
with y'all uh if you or someone you know
uh has a story you think will be great
for the show submit it at
honeydewpodcast gmail.com
and make sure everybody you know is
subscribed when your story comes on all
right now i'm highlighting the low
lights
stories behind the storytellers
uh and i'm gonna just read the subject
that came to me and i said i definitely
want to talk to this guy so this is how
it read orphan
died twice
two-month coma took 148 pints of blood
in 12 hours ladies and gentlemen please
welcome ian woodford y'all
ian thank you for being on the show
thanks for having me yeah man that's a
hell of a [ __ ] headline um that's
definitely attention grabbing so um
real quick uh where are you
in the world in ohio ohio all right and
um
what do you do for a living
um
nothing anymore man i'm kind of
permanently disabled but i uh i work on
cars i make you do videos here and there
oh yeah i don't know i like when all i
control i bought like 14 cars that were
complete [ __ ] and i just completely
stripping down to bear nothing paint
them completely rebuild engines
and i put it up on youtube
you flip them
you sell them i should i should have i
should but i keep them i fall in love
with them man once you put all that time
into it you're like i can't get rid of
that yeah
all right so
let's start with orphan what happened uh
when you were a kid
oh man um
when i was three my dad died um
i which was my mom used to bring it up
all the time i uh i really don't
remember him too much he was a big car
guy so that's probably where i get it
from he owned like rolls-royce
dealerships and owned a couple bars
and um
when i was three but uh
the night that he died instead of saying
good night to him like i did every night
my mom said i said goodbye and he died
that night asleep
so she's always said that i could
predict the future when i was little
just because of that one thing i don't
think anything else happened but she
would always say that so at three you're
being raised by a single mom and then
what happens
uh she went back to school to be like a
nurse in rn and then um we moved down to
florida like uh seminole florida st pete
area and um
she uh just ran nursing home she became
like director of nursing had a couple of
different ones
and then i have a sister's 12 years
older than me
and we were down there until i was
probably 12
and i was just a mama's bully for a very
long time i got whatever i wanted
because we had good money then when she
was running nursing homes okay so i just
want so orphan
you were not born without parents you
lost your parents
yeah just being clear on that okay at
what age did your mom pass
14 right she committed suicide and i
found her oh
what happened are you comfortable
talking about it
yeah man i uh like i was saying we were
down in florida and i got an older
sister she had a son and we were worried
that he was
they were doing all these tests they
thought he was gonna have leukemia
so she just got rid of everything and we
came up here and lived with my mom's
friend
and then
um there's just one thing after another
my mom couldn't get a job up here
and then she bought a house and i was
back when you could get like two loans
she went to one bank and then
immediately went to another bank and got
loans from two different banks to buy
this house and then she can't get a job
and then in florida
insurance down there it's not like that
up here down there it's like uh an sr 22
like you have to like your
license gets suspended immediately if
you don't pay your insurance
but she canceled it down there and then
got insurance up here
but they suspended her license and then
during the winter she only had like this
railroad drive
suv from being in florida we she slid
down the driveway back into this
doctor's car or whatever who uh
they were like going to take her to jail
and everything because her license was
suspended in florida
and then um
just with bills and everything
she ended up she was diabetic and i had
cancer and um
i don't know i would um actually had a
nightmare that night and i uh crawled in
the bed with her and then i uh woke up
to the phone call
to the phone ringing and um
she was blue
wait man you climbed into bed with her
before do you or you do you know if she
was dead yet when you got in no she she
definitely wasn't because i like
snuggled up with her and stuff and then
the morning she took all her
yeah
yeah like i probably went with around
midnight and i woke up at nine in the
morning to a buddy of mine calling
and it was on like
uh i can't remember what day it was but
i knew my mom would be pissed that he
was gone early so i like hurried up
rushed up answered the phone was like
hey man i'll call you right back
and i jumped out of her bed and as i was
trying to grab the phone that was over
her
i think she was all blue
[ __ ] because i was four i was 14. yeah i
was 16 when i saw it too i know what
that [ __ ] feels like
it dude it
i don't know everyone
i don't know i just kind of live with it
i guess i don't know i called 9-1-1 they
told me
and they told me to give her cpr and i
did and she was blue and then she like
i don't know you know she started
throwing up and stuff
man i'm sorry to hear that's how i
became an orphan
so you're on your own at 14 then
uh yeah kind of i uh my sister couldn't
handle me she was she was only 12 years
older than me you know so i went and
lived with my mom's
friend there for a little bit
and we just weren't vibing
at all like
i would just go around the house and cut
the wires to anything that plugged in
like anything like she got she got a
brand new dell computer
you know i don't remember what year that
was but they were like super expensive
and she got like a brand new tv
and as soon as she'd plug it in she
would go to bed that night i'd just cut
the wires just cut them just acting out
yeah
yeah man because it was i don't know she
just kept wanting me to go to therapy
and all this and it's like you just go
when you i told you what happened 10
times and now you just want me to take
all these drugs that make me a zombie
and she would get mad at me if i
wouldn't take this adderall and if i
want to take this and i wouldn't take
that i was like i don't i don't talk to
anyone at school when i take that i just
sit in the back of the room i don't like
any of that [ __ ] right
so i ran away to florida live with my uh
mom's uncle for i don't know
maybe three months
and then i ran away and i just went up
the hood over by tropicana field with um
there was like an orphanage but not
really an orphanage across the street
from my uncles there was a lady that
fostered kids and how old are you at
this point
when you're there 16 maybe okay
so
um
me and antoine just
like we're [ __ ] out of here and we
just went and lived in the hood and
did whatever we had to do to make a
couple bucks who's there staying trapped
houses cousin
no he's just the next door yeah
and you just bounced around down there
until what you gotta
now you said no my cousin actually came
and got me
from there like uh tropicana
back then was like
i don't know i keep i said this and
someone actually told me that it was be
way after this but
there was a little black kid that got
shot by a white cop that has work on
down there and like you couldn't even be
white and go and drop a can at this time
but i could because i was with antoine
and all these other orphan kids that
grew up down there
i was like the only white kid and
anywhere around tropicana field at that
time like cops wouldn't come in i
remember i called my uncle one time he
was like i'm not coming there he wanted
me to go 20 miles for him to come pick
me up and i've stayed there for a while
i didn't know it was bad around
tropicana it is huh i was talking to a
couple friends down there they said they
cleaned it up a lot okay
so so i don't even
i don't i don't want to make you relive
too much of that but i do want to hear
about this [ __ ] accident i mean die
oh dude that's the that's the mean
potatoes of the story let's talk about
it what what how old are you what's
going on that day walk us through the
whole day
i uh so after all that i was down in
florida
my cousin richie was like
this is stupid you're doing whatever you
can to make money you're i was literally
living in a trap house to where the only
way in the house was a doggy door they
had siding over all the doors and
windows so the cops couldn't come in
yeah
you had to crawl through a doggy door to
get it
through thorn bushes holy [ __ ]
and like it was all nothing but
prostitutes on the first floor and then
people cooking [ __ ] on the second floor
it was all just set up like that and it
was 10 bucks a night so you could pay
for that and where do you sleep in a
place like that a cot a bunker floor
yeah yeah
and then um
like i said my cousin came and picked me
up and
that's when i started actually like
liking cars because we'd go buy a car
for like 500 bucks
fix it up here and there so for a
thousand 1500 bucks
but then i came up back to ohio on my
18th birthday
and um that's a whole another thing i
skipped all these people that i was
staying with there's a couple other
people in between there were getting
social security from the government to
take care of an orphan i didn't even
know about it i wasn't getting any of
that i wasn't saying
so the only reason there was a big
argument when i ran away from my uncle's
house
and my cousin wanted to take me
and he rather had me stay in tropicana
then go live with my cousin because he
didn't want the social security to go to
my cousin
yeah because is that a thing so security
all this stuff
yeah there was social security i was
thought i lived with him the whole time
they didn't know they ran away so he was
still getting like 1300 bucks a month
for
a year
that hadn't lived there
so on my 18th birthday the checks come
to you for a year they give you like a
year to get your [ __ ] together
i know exactly how it goes but i only
got it until
it was like a month after it was like
three months it was
i think it was whatever comes first it
was 18 or um
graduation and i i got it i turned 18 in
march so i only got it for like three
months once i graduated high school then
they they took it away
well the there is a there's a
older uh lady at the social security
office who kind of told me how to
manipulate that
well you can get it as long as you are
enrolled in the school i see
so like i was 18 and i kind of and i
technically dropped out so i like
enrolled in like some choices program
and they're like as long as you're in
school you can get it up to another year
in three months
so i got it until i was 19 in three
months i wish i'd known that
but then um so yeah i came up here with
my first check that i actually got i
came up here to see all my friends i
went to school with and stuff and then i
ended up just staying up here
and moving in with my one friend there
and then um i don't know once my
social security started running out my
brother-in-law my sister's husband
um he pours concrete
and he was like you can come work for me
if you want no one thought i was going
to want to do it i loved it like
immediately i loved just having like a
family like i just took it all in like
like all we did was bust each other's
balls all day they just built because i
never really had like that father figure
i think i just like wanted that like i
miss it to this day like i for real
still have dreams about just going
important driveways
really yeah well like yeah just open
parking lot a concrete just sitting
there pouring straight edging raking i
dream about that [ __ ]
it's so just
you like earn your money and yeah you're
happy
so that's what i started doing i did
that for a very long time from well not
really a very long time from 18 until
26
what almost four years ago is when the
accident happened i was uh
i had was you know pouring concrete
forever just
working like 90 hours a week i would
work 45 to 50 hours at my
uh job and then i'd do side jobs or go
work for other union companies that
needed scabs after hours and stuff like
that i did i loved it
and then um
my daughter is coming out here
and then um
so yeah i was poured concrete non-stop
all the time and then um
that day i uh
it was actually raining i really don't
remember do you remember
it was august 18th i think it was
wednesday 2016. okay
and um it was raining and you can't put
concrete in the rain so we all like went
out to breakfast and then
my bus was like well if you want to work
you can take the dump truck and
the bobcat and the excavator and go get
this job ready you and nick and nick was
in the dump truck in front of me with
the bobcat i was in a dump truck behind
him with gravel and an excavator
yeah like i'm heavy i'm in a full sized
dump truck with a trailer with a
full-size excavator on the back and you
have a load of gravel do you have a load
in the truck too
yeah i had some gravel okay so you have
gravel and the trailer and everything on
it you are yeah okay
and um i'm coming down a hill
um it's state street it's what it's
called i'm coming down straight at the
hill it's raining at this point right
now no okay no it actually got really
nice this is i don't know it was raining
all morning
i don't know by like nine o'clock it
started getting nice out
and um
i was coming down the hill and um there
was a lady
so like you're coming down state street
and there's a road right here but it's
only a right-hand turn or left-hand turn
it dead ends into a cornfield
there's a lady waiting for me to go by
there's a guy in a crane truck coming
trucking down the other side of the hill
because you go down in this valley
and
i don't know it's never been proven but
everybody even people at his company say
he was texting and driving he says he
fell asleep
um
but uh
he i guess slipped up seen her
clipped her
the best thing that could have happened
in the whole entire world that day
was to be pushed her she's like some
just
right out of high school girl in this
little
focus she would have been demolished in
between those two trucks oh so he clips
her driver's side tail light and pushes
her into the field
and then hits me straight on his crane
comes through takes off this side of my
face all the way back to my ear what my
my steering wheel cuts me in half
what
it does i'm like i was going to send you
pictures i forgot jesus cuts me in half
holy [ __ ] dude hold on a second hold on
a [ __ ] second you're talking about
you're coming down the hill you're not
no breaks for you either right so
neither one of you are breaking at all
at this point i didn't
because i had the right of way right i'm
going downhill i'm going straight for
another 100 miles there isn't even
anything or maybe sleeping but he looks
up at the last moment jolts hits her
knocks her in the cornfield and [ __ ]
straight on to you
dude cut your [ __ ]
say it again dude i wish i could
i wish i sent you the pictures you'd see
it like dude this truck isn't demolished
it's just wrinkled mess is a big boy
and um the crane comes through
hits me in the face and peels my face
like just like a razor blade do you feel
it all the way to the bone i don't
remember any of this none of it
and your steering wheel cuts you in half
like it just you fall you push forward
that hard
yeah the standard patrol said i usually
hit over a hundred g's they mark me as
dead
so like they
even the insurance company everything
was uh catastrophic like i wasn't
supposed to make it at all they gave me
like a five percent chance to make it
through the night all right so what
happens you get hit like that and what
do you remember do you remember or what
are you told then what happened i i got
in it was first thing it was we were
running late because we went out to
breakfast because it was supposed to
rain
and
so it's like 9 15 i think is when 911
was called everyone's going to work
i got a [ __ ] ton of reports and
witnesses and everything so your friend
did your friend that was ahead of you
see it
i'll get there okay you're all excited i
am i can't get over this [ __ ] story
all right go ahead so i i'm coming down
the hill i get hit in the face the crane
takes it all the way back my ears off
like it's skin it's all still together
though i peel back
and i uh my stroke cuts me in half
and then
i'm like wrapped up from i've heard
a couple there's a couple different
reports but
most of the reports say
that i kicked my door open
and you know how on like a big dump
truck a diesel truck like that the fuel
tank the diesel tank is part of the
steps to get in yeah
that wasn't [ __ ] there man so i go to
get out and the steps are wrinkled up
like this the steps are wrinkled up
comes right through me and out
and cuts up through my liver
oh and by the way
hold
wait all right hold on did you just say
all your ribs came out of your back yeah
i forgot to say that
i have scars from ribs coming out my
back jesus christ
i told this story a lot man so wait
you're telling me that
you don't remember obviously but just
force a habit you kick the door open and
you're about to step down that's why
your body is dropping so quick you're
expecting a step to be there i guess i
don't like it i don't remember i just
and that's bent up and it's [ __ ] just
slices you yeah i go to step out and i
fall and it cut it cuts my liver right
in half good comes right through
comes straight up and cuts me in half
and that's after the accident
yeah
and then my brother-in-law who's
probably the closest
person to me my family like me and my
sister hasn't really got along that much
and um
he's in the truck ahead of me so he
comes back because he's all he gets up
to the light
300 yards 400 yards away he's like where
the [ __ ] is he
turns around he just sees it's like a
bomb went off he said there's a [ __ ] in
the air still dust and [ __ ] everywhere
cars parts everywhere he comes running
over
and he's like he's he said he thought i
was dead he's like i just seen you all
mangled up
and he said he came over to me and he
was like i didn't want to [ __ ] touch
you
he's like i was just staring at you
and then just all of a sudden i started
screaming your name so like the corn he
says it's corny all the time and he's
gonna hate that i say this
but we used to watch lone survivor
non-stop
and remember when he gets hurt he gets
shot in the leg he's like get your
[ __ ] legs working
he said he just started screaming that
to me he's like yeah man get your
[ __ ] legs where he said i looked up
because i was laying like this he said
after he yelled that at me so i looked
up my face just fell off
because it got peeled back
you're like i'm trying to get up but my
face is falling off
so
holy [ __ ] so this poor dude not poor you
really but he's traumatized looking at
you his you're his brother-in-law you
said
yeah he's married to my sister face is
falling off your liver you're probably
bleeding out your ribs are out through
your body oh yeah i'm bleeding out right
punctured my temporal artery from the
crane punctured this artery what
and then my collarbone everything's
broke inside of here man my collarbone
punctured my clavicle artery so i'm just
spraying blood out arteries oh my god
and there's people going to work seeing
this [ __ ] having their coffee
yeah
[ __ ]
so what happens
so the ems comes
my like i said my brother-in-law just
keeps yelling at me he says scared to
touch me he's a big dude like i i look
small now but i like you support conch i
used for concrete i used to be like 200
pounds right now i'm like 150 and still
can't gain the weight back
and um
he's just throwing tires throwing axles
like the axle the front axle of the
truck is gone
and just
i forgot to send the pictures man you
can email me email them to it uh tell me
yeah but i'm i'm just sitting here the
the other reason i'm blown away is
because i know
you could do it after we're done talking
you don't need to do it right now but i
know the size of these trucks
so to be to be missing an axle on this
[ __ ] thing like that dude yeah i mean
it's like did you ever say how fast that
they thought he might be going when he
hit you
no but i believe that speed on his 55 so
we were both at least doing that i was
going
yeah so i was unstoppable right like i
just
it was done man
so
like
so
i and then here's where stuff gets
stories stories again so
they called
uh
i don't know i they called for a
life flight to come
the ems shows up
as two other guys
and nick's like my brother-in-law
says can i start moving this [ __ ]
because i'm stuck in between everything
still trucks are all wrapped up you
can't even get to me he starts ripping
trucks apart
they end up getting me out waiting and
jaws
guys
no they didn't no they they probably
should have but they didn't have time
they just surf my brother started
freaking out
but uh
he uh
i supposed to take a the helicopter and
then the one ams guy is like
the one report says i didn't have a
pause so he pretty much was like he's
dead on scene so they did it now the
other guy
yeah and then the driver is like i can
give him the ultimate hospital faster
than that chopper can get here throw
them in the bus
and they did
they got me to all men they got me back
and the ambulance they got brought me
back i got to ask you you don't have any
memories nothing you didn't see anything
no lights none of that [ __ ] you hear
about i've tried i hear you oh i i i'm
going to get to that
so they are throwing them for two months
they throw you in the back of an
ambulance
you're pronounced dead at this point and
they're taking you to the hospital to
see if they can revive you and they do
do they do it in the ambulance or do
they do it when they i believe yeah i
believe they do it in the ambulance once
they get me to the hospital
and then all these nurses
are on like first name be like i'm their
miracle child at this hospital because
like
148 pints of blood that's yeah
12 hours right we said that in the
second i took more than that total
i took like 152 total all right so do
you know what like they bring you in do
you know what they did to you like the
procedures and things they're doing too
yeah they just brought me in and started
trying to figure out what was going on
they didn't know that this
collar bone went through this artery
they just see this one spraying
everywhere this one's spraying inside of
me oh so there's pump and blood and they
got the blood machines hooked up to it
and then i got three nurses squeezing
blood bags this like when i went to
leave the one nurse was just crying
she's like my hands still hurt like i
still think about just sitting there
squeezing blood for hours oh and my
brother-in-law was in there he said that
the floor was just like there was a
flood he was like it was just [ __ ]
yeah oh just a flood of blood everywhere
he's like it was just like being in like
a swamp or something just
blood everywhere from what he's like
because he was allowed to be in there
with me
and then um
yeah then after that they just start
doing a whole bunch of [ __ ] i was going
to get my wife out here but because she
was there and she knows a lot of it but
she's like tell me about this ribs going
like what do they do to that like it
actually punctured your skin and
everything
yeah i got some scars but
you can't really see them because i
don't have any ab muscles so i wear a
binder
to keep my intestines in place
what happened why because the what the
steering wheel did to you the damage it
caused yeah well like
i got cut so bad and they kept getting
infected that they had to keep
you got to see the pictures they
i have no muscles at all you see
intestines and stuff so they skin graft
over there to keep me alive
so you have no
abdominal muscles at all right now no
how the [ __ ] do you sit up how do you
take a [ __ ] man how do you pull it
[Music]
yeah you guys like the [ __ ] the poo
talking yeah i i actually put i do man
listen you know what i'll [ __ ] be
honest with you yeah i want to know how
do you [ __ ]
i i put have like you know like your
little uh trash bins for the
i put that over on my left foot okay and
i keep my left foot up on that trash bin
i lean into my leg
and then push it that way yeah because i
don't have the muscles
you have to fold your body in order to
push it yeah or like i'll put my arm
like you can't really see what i'm doing
like i'll put my arm here and pull it
i'll lean into my leg
in the morning jesus christ dude
what what are you supposed to be trying
to get that all fixed what does the
series feel like does the sneeze hurt
bring it bring it down a little more
come back give me a little less head
room yeah there you go oh look yeah
that's good that's good what is this do
sneezes hurt
yeah yeah sneezes are
all right so you're in there we're not
even i know
i know we're not even close to it yet so
take me back all right they're pumping
blood the lady's crying her hands still
hurt it's a bloodbath everywhere
literally on the floor yes so
they hit well i skipped the part where
they my arms also all like i got skin
grass over here like this used to be a
tattoo
they uh i was fighting i don't remember
that at all like i guess as soon as
it wasn't nick like when it was nick i
was fine
as soon as other people started grabbing
me i just started freaking out and
swinging and just fighting and being a
dick and then they would immediately go
to yeah
but my brother he told me that i would
immediately start fighting these guys
telling them to get the [ __ ] off of me
and this and that and then immediately
start begging for help
and so they hypoketamine
and they blew my arm out because i was
fighting so much
so the hemoketamine just blew my whole
arm out because they missed it
oh and then
so that got super infected and that's
why that's so bad they just had to keep
taking skin off of that so that's not
even from the accident
no oh my god but it looks horrible
you didn't have enough problems already
yeah
and so like i'm on life support right
i'm in a coma
and this crazy [ __ ] is happening like i
remember some weird [ __ ] yeah what do
you remember tell us
like
talk to people all right i tell this to
everybody i talk about it on my youtube
channel all the time
anyone you know in a coma
just [ __ ] talk man i heard i hear you
oh i heard you this is great to know
because a friend of mine had a horrible
accident she did end up passing but
there was a time where she was in a coma
for a few days and they said
they told us not to touch the head like
don't come touch her hey she was 16 too
like a sister they said to her mom all
of us don't touch her hair they were
saying that touching the head
makes the brain um you know start
gosh i don't even know what to say act
you know um activate is i guess a better
word for lack of a better term and um
that was not a good thing because she
had a brain injury so we would talk to
her and i could see like her eyes behind
moving and things like that so i always
wondered
if she ever really felt like that's
yeah well like my that that's that's a
big [ __ ] part that i missed i can't
believe i did that my best friend
actually died
a couple months in a car accident before
my accident really
yeah like my
he was actually older than me but after
my mom died he was like
it's probably a good 20 something years
older than me but i always know his yard
and then after my mom died he was like
just stepped up to help try to be my
father figure while i was still in ohio
live with my aunt because my aunt or i
say my aunt but it was my mom's best
friend my aunt cece they're just friends
she
i would just go over there and he'd just
keep me busy trying to you know chop
this wood do this do that
and that had [ __ ] hurt so bad that
like
sounds [ __ ] up but that was probably
rougher on me than my mom maybe because
i was just young at the time and
or maybe it was because she was there if
my mom was going home
you've already suffered so much loss and
now they're stacking up
yeah but
like
he was in a coma and he had a well set
up to where it was full of plug
and like i didn't really talk to him
that much because
i was like he's [ __ ] dead you know
what i mean
but
when i was in my coma
i couldn't
i knew it was in the hospital which is
super weird but like sometimes someone
would be talking to me and i would be
somewhere else
and having that conversation
what because specifically do you
remember hearing any specific sentences
or yeah i remember
oh not like full-blown like i can't
remember like full-blown conversations i
just know that i had them and people had
them and like
my brother-in-law was there with his son
my nephew and they had donuts
and i said that when i got up i was like
you guys are there eating donuts and i
wanted a donut
like i remember that i remember they
were in the hallway
and then i also remember one nobody hit
you with the talladega height uh knights
mike honcho confessions
no one was poured out their heart to you
now
if it ain't old mike show himself shake
it back buddy
so you remember donuts and when you came
out of the coma you said that and that
they they were like yeah that's right we
were there yeah well yeah i remember
like my i just from like i would say i
don't remember the exact things i spent
four years but i remember like talking
to people and one of the times we only
talked about me supposedly dying once
another time they tried to scan me
they tried to scan me before this coma
and [ __ ] that i was talking about they
tried to scan me and like the tube thing
i can't remember mri cat scan or
whatever it is and the one nurse was
like
you just gotta [ __ ] make it to this
so we know what's wrong
and i remember her saying that to me
but the thing is weird is that the cat
scan tube thing in my mind was in a shed
in a wood shed and the tube was made out
of wood and it was just super weird
and i just remember it being you know
those things are super loud i remember
it being loud but i remember her talking
to me she's like you just got to stay
alive for this so we know what's going
on just stay a little bit longer
holy [ __ ] i just remember a lady saying
that and then it was tiffany you said i
that was me and she was also one of the
girls that was squeezing blood
so you i remember people saying stuff to
me and accurately you remember it
accurately like those things really did
happen that wasn't something you were
making up like i know that the wood and
all that sure your brain yeah like it's
just super weird and like one time i was
like in an alleyway talking to a couple
of my friends that came to see me i
don't remember the conversation i
couldn't remember it when i first woke
up but i remember like we were hanging
out in an alleyway like smelling my
cigarette and we were talking and they
came to talk to me and
i was like
and i remember talking to you when's the
second time you were pronounced dead
it was while they were trying to fix me
in surgery
because i took like 28 surgeries or
something like that something crazy
sometimes during that you were
pronounced then they brought you yeah
yeah damn dude what's his name dr
coleful
because like
after
it's all said and done you know i'm in a
coma for a
for two months i was gonna call for two
months
first they didn't know if i was gonna
make it to the night they gave me like
five percent chance and then i ended up
coming through and then they were like
all right well we gotta figure out what
the [ __ ] is going on
and they started you know doing
exploratory surgeries and figuring this
out and sewing this back up my liver is
cut in half i have kidney failure i'm on
dialysis all during the coma they're
doing this to you
yeah god so
so and
i'm just
sorry
when you're no you're fine man when
you're in a coma and they have to do
surgery can they give you
um
can they put you under or are you
already technically under like how does
that [ __ ] work
well i mean could you feel concrete
i work on jdm cars man come on could you
feel being cut open or anything like
that do you have memories of surgeries
no but after i was in a coma like i had
a wound vac on
like i keep saying i wish i would have
seen the pictures see how big this
[ __ ] thing was
i just opened i was open for a very long
time
because i don't have any muscles so
take these pictures dude jesus
yeah i've seen some [ __ ] tom has shown
you you'll be fine
segura has traumatized me dude
so you're good
but
so like they would do wound back changes
and uh what's that [ __ ] uh
michael died on uh propofol profile
they'll put you on to get you this in
the zone to like do small stuff like
that they were doing it so often and i
was on so much [ __ ]
that it stopped working and i would wake
up a couple of times whether you're
doing these wound back changes
and like i'll just be on pieces
and you could you see it did you look
down and see your body like that yeah
but i was on life support and [ __ ] still
so
damn dude i started tracing so i
couldn't talk and you can't move
like
i don't know man you ever hear the
eminem song of rose
where he talks about that that's exactly
how it was like the nurse comes in
saying this is gonna use their family
and
you you you know that [ __ ] even though
you
that's i listen to that song like three
times a week it's so crazy it came out i
believe like a couple
a year after my accident or something
like that
so two months of coma you're in the
hospital
what
what when do you do you remember waking
up do you remember opening your eyes and
what's the i don't remember the first
time i was in and they didn't
they didn't know if i was ever going to
actually come all the way back
because i would come back and it was
like
it's you're super just fuzzy
like you constantly it's like being in a
movie almost like
you ever like watch a movie where like
someone gets put into like a crazy home
and they're like they're like am i crazy
you start thinking that because you wake
up every day and you're like so what
happened i got hit by a truck
oh yeah all right and then you do this
and then they're nervous that you keep
asking that and it's like as soon as you
tell me i remember that i asked it
i just can't remember
that that i asked it until i asked you
and then i'm like oh yeah [ __ ] i asked
that yesterday and ian you were 19 you
said
at the time no
no i was 26. okay all right so i'm
thinking i was worried that that you
have no parents or anything i was
wondering who's in there making
decisions whether you well that that did
i just it was just all luck and the
people that
i just had
i don't know just maybe because of all
the [ __ ] i did it was just my time
to have some good luck everybody was
there for me like even the emts
they like never come back they see [ __ ]
all the time right yeah they came back
we're all like i just want to make sure
the dude wasn't alone damn
that's nice so so like
i don't remember we keep jumping around
yeah i had a stroke too like
that
yeah when i woke up and they told me
what happened well i had a stroke i
don't know for sure 100 no one knows
exactly when it happened
because they could just see that like i
had what you call it's in my brain
because they would wake me up from time
to time and then like you'd go zonked
back out like you don't just
it's not like a movie at least it wasn't
for me and maybe other people it is but
you're not in a coma for two months you
wake up and go walking down the [ __ ]
street your muscles don't work
anymore because you've been in a [ __ ]
bed for two months
so
they
would wake me up and then they told me i
i just kept remembering that i hurt
somebody
that's all i kept thinking because
because they would i thought they were
lying to me
and that and i think that's why i
stroked out because i would remember
waking up like i said i didn't remember
until
they told me and then i remembered and i
would freak out because i'd wake up and
be like what the [ __ ] is going on like
you can't talk really you just mouth it
and you can't move like you want to make
a fist you want to scream you can't
yeah i'd like barely hit the side of the
bed like just
to ask for help and [ __ ]
but uh
they would tell me and i just kept like
my biggest fear in that truck especially
that older truck because it was just old
was hitting like a family and like a
minivan or a prius or something like
that like coming down that hill like
dude that thing would be like a soccer
ball
so that's what i kept thinking happened
i thought they were lying to me
because they were all like no someone
hit you
and i was like no man just tell me
are they okay and this and that and the
other guy was fine his truck was like
brand new he got wrapped in airbags
but
i think he did two days in the hospital
but no jail time no any of that
yeah did he ever come to check on you
no dude that's the thing that pisses me
off the most and everyone's like well
his attorney or whatever probably told
him not to i couldn't live with myself i
couldn't either i would have sent
flowers or something
yeah dude i would like
i would work [ __ ] quadruple time to
make sure his family was fine
you know i mean like during all that
like i lost my house during this
oh my fiance had to go back and live
with her parents and take my uh at the
time one-year-old daughter my daughter
pulled all her hair out because i had
her all the time
like she was
she was a daddy's girl for sure like me
and it was just she pulled all her hair
like she just would pull it out and eat
it
oh at like a year oh shoot may have been
two
maybe i don't even think
dude i have to say this though hearing
everything that happened to you you look
damn good i mean i'm i'm talking about
what i'm seeing facially
you look your [ __ ] face you can't
really see it i try to do a good job of
hiding it let me see dude
i mean listen man i hear you but whoever
whoever whoever did the work on you did
a damn good job considering what i'm
hearing
i think you look remarkably well
considering i know you just stood up and
you're like i don't even have abs but
yeah i don't like it's all up here too
broke like we can go on and on and on i
can keep you here for three hours just
talking about like my sternum was broke
and then they put me back together with
wires which once i finally did get up
moving
i the wires rubbed through and was gonna
punch my heart so they had to go back in
and take those out
it's all been yeah it's been a nightmare
but
so
we're in the coma for two months right
and i get up and then i go to like ltch
where
they like
it you go to die pretty much
this didn't know what was going to
happen
and then i start doing therapy i'm the
youngest one in there by the way too so
like it's just all like nursing home
people who come there to pretty much die
and this and that and then
i'm still on a trach and all this [ __ ]
so i can't really talk and then um
do that trying to walk socks dick dude
like i mean i want to know like
well let's go back for a second because
you wake up out of this coma
and then what then they they say you
still have to stay in the hospital we're
moving you to this you called it l-tech
and that's where you're gonna you're
either gonna make it or you're not
basically
yeah pretty much well like i was in the
sicu which is just the icu but for
surgical
it's like the surgical intensive care
unit or whatever for surgery and i was
in there for longer than i think anyone
else ever they said ever that they ever
yeah that they had there because they
usually just go there for surgery but
they didn't know what else i was gonna
need like
i was there for a long time and like i
said i took uh like 148 pints of blood
the first 12 hours like i don't
i don't know if that's ever some of the
nurses said that's not even we already
know how it's possible that there's no
way that's ever happened before some
people are like
and your body just kept bleeding out
internally and yeah because they didn't
know that i was
punctured here and then so like i had a
hole here
i had holes here from the ribs where
blood was coming out i had holes over
here this whole side of me is full of
shrapnel so i'm still just bleeding
everywhere
and then i have the hole from the steps
and then my whole stomach
so they don't know where the [ __ ] the
blood's coming from
and then the agostino who's the chess
doctor he's like
you can google him he like was like one
of the best in the country came here for
like some special deal he like runs his
own thing at the hospital he came in
and like i guess just pretty much
i i i'm sure it's over his head over
exaggerated but the nurse that was in
there with him his nurse was like yeah
he came running down he's a big dude a
big big doctor he's like i've never seen
him run so fast and was running in
once they tell him what happened and he
just
opens me up sticks his hand up and grabs
my artery and squeezes it and it's like
give me clamps clamps it and i start
beeping again
holy [ __ ] dude
but a lot of people say that's over
exaggerated but that's what you know
that's pretty much what that's like
that's pretty much what happened oh
[ __ ]
so all right so now your physical
therapy and mentally you know that you
have to learn how to walk again and it's
that has to be frustrating to mentally
know i can do this and i've done this
and not to get the body to cooperate
you don't even
know how to
yeah
yeah
i was a weak pouring concrete and now i
can't [ __ ] walk is that why you
haven't had any parents or anything ever
to help me before now i got all these
people trying to help me to learn how to
walk and i'm just a dick dude would you
say i i could understand the anger
coming out of that but would you say
that of all the things was learning how
to walk one of the hardest again
yeah it was why what is
is it trying to get well because
well i'm better now because i i just i i
just got my wheelchair right now
no no i can walk on everything i
shouldn't be able to i need a new knee
that's another thing too my kneecap came
off off
it just never ends dude we can just keep
i can just keep thinking am i going to
keep telling you i'm also what are you
how old are you 30
uh yeah i will be in february yeah i was
talking about four years ago so
i mean you're going to have a lot of
problems when you get older with
arthritis [ __ ] off
i mean you know you are i'm glad you're
here but you know it you said it never
ends i guess it's never going to end
yeah it never ends man
man i feel like i'm missing a bunch of
[ __ ] you you're missing abs bro yeah
yeah but i i plan on having my fiance or
i call it my wife and we've been
together for so long to help me go
through this stuff because she was there
the whole time i always forget stuff oh
i see of course you you went through a
[ __ ] major accident all right so talk
to us about learning how to walk again
it's just horrible it's just nothing
works like you don't think about you'd
been in bed for so long i had a stroke
this whole side of my body it was
affected this like it's good now but
like i have permanent nerve damage
to where so like it's just this arm is
actually still technically broken
but i mean it's not anymore because it
obviously heals itself but for the
longest time i couldn't move my wrist
more than you can see i couldn't move my
wrist more than that over that way
and but now i can but it was because
this was broken but i also had permanent
nerve damage that wouldn't let me do it
so for a long time i just had to keep my
arm like this so the nerves would help
heal themselves i guess i don't know
but like every now and then this you
know like when you like either like sit
on your hand or you know how you get
that tingle i just get that all the time
every now and then especially in the
pinky
this foot
and then this knee is really bad and
they said i'll probably need hips and i
just i'm not need
hopefully technology will get good and
after rogan does all the stem cell [ __ ]
yeah we'll put you back together brother
i can't believe you have a [ __ ] sense
of humor about any of this [ __ ] man
you're amazing what are you gonna do man
that sucks that's the life i it is right
what else are you gonna do it's good
that you do
so all right i think that would be [ __ ]
dude if i could get someone that'd be
like yeah let's try out stem cells on
this dude i'd [ __ ] shoot me up man i
need them everywhere
you can literally put them in anything
put it out there put it on your youtube
put it everywhere anybody else anybody
out there listening to this knows
anybody with stem cells hitting up
all right so you start learning how to
walk again
all right well you're how long are you
in therapy um still in the hospital
situation your coma for two months i was
in the hospital for 86 days i was in a
coma in the sicu for
two months in like two weeks
because i was on a coma for two months
and i think i stayed another two weeks
after that just to make sure it was all
okay so there i was also the first
patient that they ever took outside i
kept begging to go outside in the sun
and the nurses all got together one
afternoon i was like [ __ ] push them
out the door
they wheeled me out hold that out the
door
that's great i'm probably going to get
someone in trouble over saying that [ __ ]
where are y'all going with that guy
um
so the therapy wasn't in the hospital
you would go to no it was at the
hospital it was just on the next floor
no that was about another month oh okay
so now you're so you're in the hospital
still you're on a different floor and
every day you're doing physical therapy
yeah just about that it's just can i ask
you a little bit you're so like your
personal question yeah during all this
you're getting your wits back is any
part of you thinking what the [ __ ] is
the bill going to be at the end of this
[ __ ]
no
dude after i hit 2 mil i was like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i work 90 hours a week to make [ __ ]
60 grand
what was the total bill at the end of
all of this when you finally walked it
wasn't much more than two i think it was
like three or something two to three
million dollar hospital bill
[ __ ] all right sorry back to things
blood ain't cheap
yeah no [ __ ] an amount you got
yeah well especially since i took so
much of whatever the universal one is
for a long time i took like the rare one
because they didn't know what the [ __ ] i
was
this has
like
they
they gave it to me everyone was donating
blood
so
all right so therapy now you're learning
how to walk what else what else you
learn how to do
just everything like it's just it's just
a slow process of them trying to come in
every day and try to get you up and for
the long for
probably three weeks two three weeks
you're just
getting to sit up they just get you out
of bed and you're just [ __ ] [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] and this and this
cause they're literally just making you
sit there and then they [ __ ] leave
because you're a dick and you're stuck
there in [ __ ] pain and you go and you
slouch over and you're like hey [ __ ]
i can't get up
it just sucked and then i love those
girls now but during all that you're
like the mean old man in the nursing
home like there was nothing i could do
about it i hated everything i didn't
want to move yeah i understand i didn't
it was non-stop all the time i was just
i did nothing but complain
my fiance sitting there fighting with
people that are just trying to help me
because i'm upset it got
it was
she has my back
that's good man
your ribs dude
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i appreciate you letting me take shots
dude you're good man
all right so what happens after rehab
you they move you out of the house
i'm pretty much in bed for two years man
okay so let me ask you this is it sort
of
i just have to know that are they like
all right we did whatever we could here
your see you later and they just shove
you back out into the world and you're
on yeah that's pretty much how it was
like it was it was fruit yeah it kind of
sucked i mean all the nurses care about
me and i go and i see them all the time
my main doctors all still care about me
but it's like the hospital's thing like
what are they supposed to do so are you
like on a walker or cane crutches what
are you or no i'm not gonna lie when you
leave
yeah somewhere along the line i like hit
my like little rocky moment to where i
was supposed to stay another like month
and i was like i gotta be out before
thanksgiving
like so they were gonna send me to a
rehab facility like a nursing home
pretty much
for like another three six months
and i just i don't
i still don't know to this day how i got
out of that i just was like i would get
like i wasn't supposed to get up out of
bed without help and it got to the point
where like in the morning i'd get up and
make my bed and do all this [ __ ] and
brush my teeth by the time the therapy
girls over there they're like
dude you're not supposed to be out of
bed and so i just kept doing it and
doing it and doing it and it was it
sucked man going up steps sucks like you
can't move like i don't know how
like you just got to see it like i got a
couple of videos i guess on youtube
probably it just
you just can't
i don't know how to explain nothing
works nothing you tell [ __ ] to do [ __ ]
and it just
that's good
maddening when you logically know that i
need to do this and your body won't
respond yeah or like you're walking and
you go to fall like you can't catch
yourself so you got a bunch of nurses
and they're trying to catch you and i'm
mad that i didn't catch myself so i'm
taking it out on them
it was it just
by the time it was all said and done you
know my last
couple weeks there we all were great you
know but
the therapy
that the ltch was rough because
like like i said i first went to this
room i i was super nervous of everything
like i was just like i was like ptsd or
something they could tell me i did but
with the whole
that was one of the problems i didn't
like living with my mom's friend or my
aunt because they just can't want to put
me on like medicine people kept wanting
to put me on
go to therapy and just talk to this guy
take this
pill take this adderall take it with
ritalin this and that so they kept
wanting to put me on the zoloft and all
the solution in the hospital and i just
didn't want to do it
but i was just super like
i wouldn't gain weight like at all like
i was 200 i was like 210 pounds
like the day of the accident
and i got down to like 118.
whoa that's almost 100 pounds you lost
yeah and they had me on a feeding tube
they had me on a feeding tube and they
kept wanting to take it out
but they were like if you don't gain
weight we got to put it back in so i was
like just keep that [ __ ] in
because
why i don't want i didn't want to do
anything anymore i was done son i was i
didn't want any more surgeries i didn't
want anything they kept wanting to take
my trach out instead of me just plugging
it to talk and i was like [ __ ] leave
that [ __ ] in because if i go when i fall
you're gonna have to [ __ ] drill a
hole in my neck again just i just didn't
want i just kept arguing with people
about
progressing with all the surgery stuff i
was like just let me do it and then one
night rip all that [ __ ] out of my sleep
so you did
yeah like i
i was i don't even remember it i i woke
up and like my tube was wrapped around
my hand my feeding tube and i hit the
nurse call button and i rolled over and
my trach is in my other hand like
mentally i just took all the [ __ ] out
like i don't remember doing it i was on
a lot of [ __ ] man
they
they had me on so much dope it was
ridiculous in there
that's what i'm saying to be doped up
all the time and then still even have
memories to get in there and then you
got to get off that they got to wean you
off the [ __ ] dope to get you out of
here dude i
that was my big thing they
yeah that was all [ __ ] i'll actually
[ __ ] take credit for that one because
they were sitting there telling me you
know all the girls and everything helped
me walk and all the doctors and
everything i still talked to everybody
dr van meter paulie the blood doctor
when i was they were like he's infected
he's not gonna make it she came in
changed some [ __ ] on the computer and
walked away like a wizard and i
immediately started leveling out again
so all these doctors did but they all
told me on something i was setting all
the rest of my life i was like yeah no
[ __ ] you bro [ __ ]
that's the most it took me out there it
took yeah i was on 200 micrograms of
fentanyl when i left the hospital and
eight milligrams of delighted every
three hours to combine i got to the
point yeah holy [ __ ] dude they gave that
they gave all that [ __ ] to me to die
they gave they chose
my claim
until i actually left the hospital my
insurance claim was catastrophic
is that like were they trying to give it
to you to just keep you in at ease so
you could die pieces yeah
yeah so they had me on 100 fentanyl
patch here at 100 here
and then i was on a drip for a while
like where you could hit the button of
the lotta and they said i just kept
hitting that [ __ ] so they finally just
gave me
two milliliters of iv dilated every
three hours and then when i left the
hospital i was on 200
fentanyl and eight milligram tablets
every three hours
and it was just
defending those horrible dude yeah like
everyone like people like that [ __ ] i
mean back i mean people are probably
taking a viking at a high school party
and it's been all right but this [ __ ]
ain't no [ __ ] joke i talk about it
this shit's coming over a lot from a lot
that one i saw on uh
was it netflix somewhere i saw it but it
was coming over from the middle east and
it was so pure that the fda agents were
touching it with their hands and they
were od just from touching it that's how
strong this [ __ ] can get yeah so like
these patches that i was on there like
they're pretty much nicotine patches
but
they [ __ ] you up because
they they soak into your skin so like if
you're out having a good day like if you
for two years i couldn't get out of bed
without my wife helping me out of bed i
kind of go to the bathroom i couldn't
shower and do this how you dress
yourself all that
yeah well i'm good now no i meant but
yeah
yeah so she had to help me do that put
my socks on all this and then
i'd say all that a year and a half and
then i started getting up and doing this
but
you go out in [ __ ] july in the sun to
play with your daughter
and the fentanyl just wears into your
[ __ ] skin dude and you get all that
[ __ ] like you're out with your sleeves
rolled up
and it just melts into you and you don't
know who you are for the next eight
hours
it's just stupid so i just constantly
been going to the doctor's office we're
like all right well let's lower this
dose
and you'd be are you sure and i'd be
like yeah so once i finally got down to
like
a hundred i wanted to go to 50 and he
put me on 75 and then i ended up going
down
and then
have you been here have you been able to
kick it
yeah i'm not on i haven't been on that
for a while
for you dude nope no painkillers
no i'm i still would take uh the
oxycodone here and they're like a person
tablet but
i still have massive surgeries i finally
got a couple people that think that they
could put me back together i just with
the covet and everything going on that
kind of so you have more and then my one
yeah i have a lot of stuff all right so
give me an update of where you are now
health-wise what is what's
next well once all this stuff
my my doctor my pain management that we
were just talking about was who was
great who helped me anytime i wanted to
go down he let me go down he retired
and so i was down off of the fentanyl
and off the lotted and i went to
oxycodone oxycontin you know immediate
release time release and then i got off
the oxycontin because that [ __ ] is
garbage
and then i was just on oxycode on here
and there
and then
i wanted to go down again once he
retired i went to a new doctor i want to
go down again he immediately wanted to
he was like ah all these doctors are
getting in trouble you know for
prescribing pain pills
and over prescribing he rather have had
me back on the fentanyl patch so he
could just give me one every other day
and not have to worry about it i'm not
[ __ ] doing that [ __ ] man
not so i'm trying to find a new doctor
right now
but as soon as i get that all figured
out and if i get a good pain management
doctor who's in sitting here just trying
to have me all doped up all the time and
let me have a life
i want to have that surgery done and
it's this hernia surgeon that does big
hernias
because this is pretty much a hernia you
know when you're like ripping muscle
when your intestines come out i just
don't have any muscle there at all
so he thinks he might be able to stretch
some of my back muscle around and worst
case he can do um cadaver muscles
and then i don't have anything here at
all either i have no pec muscles so he's
going to try to
i don't know give me a boob job i guess
he's got like this team yeah there's
girls out there getting asses put in
they can't put titties in you
oh man this is
your story is a hell of a story and i
know there's a lot more to it but man
i'm first of all i'm glad you're okay i
cannot believe like i'm sure you
probably can't that you made it through
that and secondly
good for you for
kicking the [ __ ] habit not just
popping pills and eating them all
[ __ ] day and because by the way
you would be a person that should be
allowed to do that you know what i'm
saying like these people that are just
like uh my life's not so great i'm gonna
take oxies or vikings like
you know that's for you to [ __ ]
really
i'm i'm really good at like faking it
like
when
i'm like super embarrassed about it
that's why like i had the light off when
we first started and
i didn't want people to really see my
face and stuff great dude when i'm out
like you can't really tell because i got
binder on and i'm just walking but i can
only be out for
you know what i mean i can't stand or
sit really for more than an hour at a
time well it sounds like you have a
great uh relationship with your daughter
you've got a great woman in your life uh
obviously you look like a young jamie
kennedy a little bit to me
it's a compliment by the way especially
after what the [ __ ] you've been through
dude this is
you have a hell of a story man you've
died
the reason why i was talking about that
was because like you go into these
i can't actually remember what i'm
saying i was talking about how i could
fake it and like i'll be in doctors like
new doctor i've seen like 11 doctors
over the past two years or something
and
she'll have to be like yeah but there's
a lot more than that happening because i
just be like yeah i got cut in half by
this and this and that or if you just
see me you don't know so you walk into
these pain pain management doctors
because i've tried to i've
i i think i've had seven doctors either
tell me that my case is too big for them
to take me on pain management doctors or
that they don't prescribe pills anymore
because doctors there's a doctor up here
that literally i believe she's doing
life
for over prescribing whoa yeah i know a
lot of these doctors doing that with
these scripts and everything so like you
look at me and you look at me and i'm
like hey i need this
they just don't ever take the time to
look at my chart and see that four years
ago i was on [ __ ] ten times a hundred
what what is that that's like 400 times
what i'm on now
because the fentanyl is 100 times
stronger than oxycodone right that's
what they say heroin oh [ __ ] yep i was
on 200 of 200 micrograms of fentanyl and
now i'm only taking a couple oxycodones
here and there today i mean that's
amazing
good for you dude i'm happy for you i i
i'm so sorry all this happened to you
but
you seem like you got a room
if i can just stay if i could just i
just miss casanova honestly he was my
best doctor after everything came and
happened
he came in
the first thing he said to me when he
met me he's like hey man they kind of
[ __ ] you up huh i was like what do you
mean he's like do you want to my
grandson
never seen that before
and so he's like you're going to be on a
fentanyl the rest of your life and then
once me and him started like once he
realize that i'm gonna keep going down
no matter what even if i gotta do uh
three days a week where the complete
withdrawal [ __ ]
i'm gonna go down and then he retires
and now i just need a doctor because i
can't
like when i found i've
found a doctor there for a little bit
that put me back on oxycontin and i
didn't for
probably two weeks ago i was in bed for
seven weeks again even though i had a
good
eight months
like it's hard to explain like i if you
you could pretty much track it on my
youtube channel you can see
two years ago i would upload
once a month twice a month then i just
get better what i'm doing a couple times
a week and then about three four four
months ago i was doing every other day
and then once he retired you literally i
haven't [ __ ] really uploaded anything
because they keep wanting to put me on
these higher doses that either just it's
just it's a roller coaster those i just
i don't know how to explain the payment
since dumb dude oh you're young too man
you're only what 30 so or come about to
be 30 so
you got a whole life ahead of you man
just take care of yourself make sure
you're around for your [ __ ] daughter
and
your soon-to-be wife whatever but um i
just want to say thank you for coming on
and sharing your story i know that
wasn't easy to talk about and
i appreciate you
you know having a sense of humor about
it here's what
you know do me a favor i want you to
email me you can send some of those
pictures but also email me the list of
um
the injuries ribs through your back you
know torn i wanna i want you to put that
i'll put it in the post
so look
thank you for coming on man for real i
really appreciate you you've been
awesome uh i wish you the best in the
future that's i know you got a rough
road ahead of you but that's that's
awesome that you're not gonna sit there
and use the pills and stuff as a crutch
and that you're really fighting to get
off and fighting to have your life back
that's really yeah man i just i
i understand that i'll never work again
but if i can go out and just tinker on a
car
and make a [ __ ] youtube video
but also dude you might be uh you know
you might be able to do some um
inspirational speaking you might be able
to go talk to kids or people who've gone
through something like this and be uh
you know be some light for them might be
something like that too don't don't ever
think you just you can't do anything
because you can definitely help
you can definitely help so thank you
thank you for doing the show i really
appreciate it
and uh thank you all out there for
subscribing if you or someone you know
has a great story please email
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com
um and i really appreciate all your
support tell everybody to subscribe
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you